and in the early 70s when i started
playing chess two players had an
outsized
influence on my chess career victor
spoople's uncle vic
and james harley mccormick jim
was really like a street fighter
he was a brawler both on and off at the
chessboard
i believe it was a washington open that
jim had come to and he hadn't yet
entered the tournament
and as he was looking around
he suddenly realized oh my goodness
a lot of the top players were simply
missing
and so he saw an opportunity to take an
easy first place of fifteen hundred
dollar
first place if you will
you waited until the very last moment
and then rushed the organizer and said
i'd like to enter the tournament the
organizer said very reasonably
sorry jim the pairings are closed the
registration is closed
and besides we have an even number of
players
if we let you in the event somebody
would
receive a forfeit and we don't want to
do that
so jim was you know really anxious to
get in the tournament because the the
first prize was a was a gimme easy
so he needed to find somebody who would
play in the tournament looked around and
he saw a guy random guy sitting down he
said excuse me do you play chess
yes said the fellow would you like to
play in the tournament said jim and he
said well i can't afford it
jim you know thought about this for a
moment and said okay i'll pay your entry
fee great
so the tournament organizer asked you
know our unknown mystery person um
were they members of the northwest chess
association no it's an extra 10
membership
were they members of the united states
chess federation no that's an extra 30
membership all of which of course was
being played paid by jim mccormick
so finally they settled down jim had
paid his dues his opponents dues his
entry fee his opponent's entry fee
the man turned out to be a chess master
from canada who defeated jim in the
first round and went on to win the
tournament
stuff of legends